yeah and thanks uh for for the
invitation
i wish i could be there with you guys um
so uh so yeah the topic uh today's topic
is you know
how how to be build an envelopes
platform
um i'm not going to talk about
definitions you know bullet points
uh you know what are the trades of an ml
flat envelopes platform or
ml platform um but i'm gonna be very
practical
and essentially um
talk about you know the practicalities
of you know
you're a small data science team you
know you start hiring data scientists
and then
what you do what are the challenges and
why my lobs are created
and then um the other half of the
presentation will be a demo of an
envelopes um
tool that i created and um
that essentially i was inspired from you
know
from all my past work experience
uh so yeah that's the
boring stuff about me i'm gonna very
quickly introduce myself so i'm a staff
data scientist at expedia
group where i'm leading the
reinforcement learning team
uh also aws awarded me this
funny title aws ml hero because i open
source the
sageify uh an emma lops uh
tool for aws um
and i've worked previously at least
workable in hotels.com
so uh let's go and start with a
you know an example let's say that you
know
you you work in a company and you know
somebody tells you that you know oh we
need a product
um recommendation system you know
uh pre product manager come to comes to
you and tells you you know
i want to put a carousel on the homepage
where
um i want you guys to recommend
products on our customers when they land
on homepage
so then you go all through all these
questions right like
why this ml system is required what is
the scope
uh how we're going to evaluate it online
is it going to be an a b test
how are we going to evaluate it offline
what are the metrics that we're going to
use
is going to be precision at k is it
going to be
ndcg if we talk if we care about the
ranking of the products
in this carousel um so
all this stuff okay where can i find all
the user item historical
data the user item interaction data
how to find the attributes of the users
and the items
then we need to build some sensible
baseline
uh so that we have a good benchmark um
are any data scientists and how many
data scientists and
software engineers required for this
project okay we have an infrastructure
to train models
how are we gonna deploy this model uh
or models is it going to be a restful
service
are we gonna do some batch predictions
every day
and then a sensor essentially cast the
predictions on the cast
and these will be served for our
customers
um how are we gonna monitor these models
you know
uh before we start the call here we're
talking about you know
all the problems of you know uh in the
travel industry when
uh you know kovit uh you know became a
thing
uh that uh you know almost all of the
models of expedia groups were invalid
because they were trained on different
like um distributions
of features so how can we be sure that
the
models that we have deployed of the
model is still behaving as
is it expected um
how to identify the flaws of a deployed
model improve it
um and then you know how to incorporate
new requests from product managers
so you know the life cycle you know
and the workflow of an ml uh project is
is huge
um and i borrowed this uh diagram
from uh chip um she's a she's a great ml
engineer
uh where um cc divided the
um you know the scope of this uh project
that you have you know the she calls it
data science here that you know it's the
business analysis
where you identify a business
opportunity like you know for example
this recommendation system uh
product management um you know piece
where you know you
you define the scope and you see for
example that you know in this specific
part you know also ml places significant
role
the data ops where essentially you know
how can we get all the data
uh how can we get you know uh refresh
training data set to retrain the model
and all this stuff
um she calls the demo engineering the
part of you know
training developing a model training
model
and then see she says that pml ops is
the part of deployment and monitoring
um and this is the the
interesting aspect i kind of disagree
here
um i believe that the mlobs
um shouldn't be part of this cycle so
it's ml engineering and data science and
mlobs is essentially
a layer that encapsulates uh data
science ml engineering and data orbs
um and that's that's an interesting fact
about these days that you know
it's a new area uh and we still haven't
figured out all the definitions
but you know let's go and start you know
let's say that you know
i'm the only data scientist in this
company that wants to build the
recommender system
so what i'm going to do is you know
probably create a jupiter notebook
uh download some data locally uh some
historical data
train some models um you know
after a couple of weeks i will say oh
you know this model
is really great let's deploy it
so then you try to find some engineer in
the company that you know
knows about restful services uh
because you know most probably well
it's it's probable that you know um that
you don't know how to
uh deploy service it happens that you
know i know but you know many data
scientists know about machine learning
not about software engineering
and then you know you give this model to
the software engineer
and you have to tell that person okay
these are the incoming features
uh that you know should be used when you
call the model
this is the output etc so that works
well when you are alone
and you have everything on your local
machine so no need for mlops
or something to essentially streamline
this process
let's say that you hire a second person
let's say you know
uh you know christos is part of the team
now we work together so
okay i'm gonna have a jupiter hub there
so we'll have a notebook some somewhere
centralized
and that would work for for quite a long
time
but as the you know the company grows
uh the teams are growing etc and
especially the engineering when the
engineering teams are growing
uh they will get back to you and they
will tell you you know
because you deploy things to production
you need to follow proper
uh practices so they will tell you why
you don't use git for example
why you don't use jenkins when you don't
use
you know some other engineering tools
why you have your code on you know
some on jupiter hub uh where you know
somebody can change the code but you
know we can't track
the code changes and then suddenly
you know the cto of the of the company
that you work at
uh wants to hire more data scientists
and you know will become
five so and you know that means that we
need to
uh have more iterations of existing
models and more models generally
speaking
um so as a first time you know by the
way experience i experience all this
stuff i work you know i'm working at
expedia group where you know it's like
20 000 employees company
i've worked at workable when it was like
i was like the employee
28 and there was a second data scientist
there and when i left workable it was
like i don't know
300 to 400 employees um
and uh yeah the first thing that you do
is that you know when you have a bigger
data science team is that you know
forget about mlabs
first thing that you need to do is
create use git
and just use some kind of template for
your uh for your code
where every data science project uses no
matter what
so in that way you know you you don't
have different styles of developing
uh things but then you have another
problem
okay we have defined the template on git
and you know that we're gonna use for
all
our ml projects but how are we gonna
track training jobs
so are we gonna use some in-house tool
i'm gonna build it i'm gonna use
ammo flow something else
how about deploying models uh now you
know because we're a bigger team
we have 10 models that we want to deploy
so but you know engineers from other
teams will be like you know i don't have
time for you
uh you figure it out um i have other
things to do for example
so how are you gonna deploy them how
are you going to help get help to to
find the the right architecture
because sometimes you you need to have
batch predictions
sometimes real time predictions with
restful services sometimes
streaming based predictions have a link
here for example if you want to
deep dive into that
how about monitoring deploy models okay
let's say that somehow you managed to
uh you know to deploy a model how are
you sure that it's you know
healthy like it's not down and affects
the the business and you know the cto
will get angry with
you um how are you sure that you know
it's making good predictions
or the input features you know have
drifted
so and many more uh you know challenges
that i i'm pretty sure that you're
facing
or you have faced in the in the past or
you're gonna face
uh so and that's why we need mlos
so we need uh you know some best
practices some
tools so that as data scientists we
focus on machine learning
and not on low-level engineering tasks
or you know how to keep track of things
like code
data training jobs results
communicate things to our colleagues to
our data scientists
communicate results to product managers
to senior management
so that's why i wanted to give you all
these challenges here
that you know i have faced personally in
the past and
to understand why mlops is required and
what kind of problems analog solves
so how how do i start you know where
five
you know let's say that you know i'm the
lead data scientist
i need to make some decisions so okay we
recently switched to cookie cutter ds
template
git perfect so every every project
follows the same pattern
suite but you know deploying a model
requires engineering help
and you know it's it's tricky to find
data scientists with coding skills
and be great at the same time you know
in ml
probably they work for facebook google
amazon
so you can't compete with them right
in terms you know salary and you know uh
problems and this kind of stuff
um and you know maybe you're lucky maybe
one of your data scientists have
software engineering skills that can do
that but
do you really want to you know for that
person to spend you know time in
engineering and not in
data science so you have some options
so you can hire software engineers to
build mlabs tools
so that's you know you have to justify
to the cto
why how many it's gonna cost you
and you know um because the
mml ml platform essentially
doesn't uh it's not close to to the
revenue
it's an enabler how are you gonna
essentially
justify this investment to do the cdo
okay another option is to go and buy an
envelopes platform
so there are many startups out there
that uh you know
do really great job but you know there's
always a risk that you know
these are startups and you don't want
you don't know if they're gonna you know
disappear
in a year from now uh and many of them
will disappear
um statistically speaking and many you
know of them won't
want you to be locked in in the in their
platform
so that it's not difficult to go
somewhere else
how about using some open source
envelopes tools
that's that's really good option uh but
still you need to
to do some engineering work to integrate
all these things
and of course there is a combination of
the above
uh just you know to let you know you
know companies like facebook have built
everything from scratch
they built their ml platform from
scratch and that happened like you know
six years ago
uh other big tech companies you know
like expedia
you know we have used you know some
in-house uh engineering tools some open
source tools
but at the same time we have software
engineers that you know uh
integrate all these pieces together and
have we have a
an ml platform
so the the key you know the key thing
here is bk
you know to be use case driven so in
this specific uh
point what we want to do is to easily
deploy models as restful services
and that's the only thing that matters
right now we don't care about you know
getting you know fancy and you know
training models in a distributed manner
or you know um we don't have complex
models like you know pythons models or
tensorflow
so we need to be very strategic here so
we have some options
either we're going to go to sagemaker
gcpa platform
seldom done bio and you know pay them
and you know they're
good they do really good job on you know
deploying models
or we're gonna go open source like
cortex.dev
that's that's really cool a piece of
software by the way
uh zen ml really good and sagify
like um like mine open source uh project
so the latter two is nml and seigify
uh you know they rely on on um paid
back-end engines like sagemaker and ai
platform
but they offer you the open source uh
abstraction layer on top of that
so what you need essentially is you know
in this template
that you have adapted to someone you
know implement a predict function
where essentially what you're doing the
predict function you say okay i'm gonna
load my model
i'm gonna write the required prediction
logic and then i will return some json
let's say some prediction
in a json format and then ideally
in a dream scenario i want a
command that's command from cd5 but some
command that where i will say
deploy you specify you know the model of
let's say on s3
or locally you specify the number of
machines that you want
that case three and the type of the ec2
machines
and then automatically that should
essentially deploy your model
uh on aws for instance so
that's in that way as a data scientist
you focus 100 on training
and you don't care how to put the model
into production
and that's the the most primitive form
of an envelopes platform essentially
later down the line you know while you
know you have more successes as a ds
team and you hire more people
then probably you get fancier when it
comes to training you know
more sophisticated models you probably
need some horsepower
uh to train these models you know on you
know bigger machines with more data etc
so that means that you know means that
you need
some um new command line where you know
you specify where all these data leaves
on s3
where you know let's say you know my
bucket training data slash
where on s3 to um i'll save the
train model let's say my bucket slash
output
and what type of machine you want to use
for training these things
and then locally on your machine you
have defined your training logic
and that command line you know again
automatically
will you know pick up the code
automatically copies the code to the
cloud
spin up cc2 instances copies the
training data to the ec2 instances
triggers the training logic saves the
model locally and then saves it on s3
so that's the more sophisticated
uh view of an envelope's platform and
later on top of that you start adding
things like okay
how to identify biases on your on my
model or when you have deployed a model
if there is some drifting on the
predictions or some drifting you know
uh on the input of features
so at the end of the day you know be
strategic on the buy versus build
you know software engineering salaries
is quite high uh
it's i think it's uh you know
interesting days that you know it
probably it's easier to to fund youth
funding for your startup than you know
finding a
really good sector engineering talent uh
you know and it's not only about
building an internal level of platform
keep in mind that you have to maintain
that so
that's a really really painful thing to
do
yeah big tech companies have you know
dedicated ml platforms like
google or facebook but you know they
have like you know tens of thousands of
engineers to do that
um and you know some other big companies
like expedia you know we use a
combination of the other options that
i've
explained and you know you need to do
some financial analysis
as a lead data scientist uh in order to
help
you know uh you know
navigate and find the best solution and
sell it to the senior management
so in my personal opinion like you know
uh the main factor of ml success in the
company is when
you enable your data scientists to focus
hundred percent on on machine learning
that's the key thing um think about you
know somebody that works let's say you
know
um at facebook uh compared to somebody
you know
in a small startup so the guy at
facebook is capable to train i don't
know tens of models every day
and then the guy in a small tech startup
you know struggle and you know they
manage to put into production only two
models
in a year obviously you can't compete uh
so you need to be strategic in order to
be able to compete
with them so
um and more and
one important thing that the last point
is that um vml platform in your
in the company it's gonna democratize
amazon learning and the predictions in
the company
one one example of that is that um for
example at expedia you know
all of our predictions of the models are
are saved in a cache so essentially
uh everybody in the business can uh you
know query these predictions
this scores and use them for their own
uh use case so you don't have to call
again the same model you don't have to
go and find me on slack and ask you know
questions how to integrate with your
model
um so my opinion um
use some ml lensing from an established
cloud provider like
you know sagemaker uh built a simple
abstraction on top of that to hide all
the details from data scientists
for me sagemaker is great but it's still
an ikea with really bad instructions
uh that's why it opens up satisfy um
and in this way because you have the
abstraction you can change the
underlying engine
in a painless manner
so uh so yeah i'm gonna show you now a
demo of sageify
uh it's uh you know it's on youtube
uh i don't do live demos because um 95
of the cases something wrong is
happening
so yeah i'm gonna show it now
i'm not sure about i'm not hearing
anything from my side
oh you're not kidding no
oh okay um sorry guys
um how can i make this happen
you're probably gonna have to share
again uh ticking the the
checkbox for share computer audio or
something
like when you're gonna share your screen
oh thanks thanks okay i'll stop starting
and reserve again
thanks
first
at the bottom left i guess is the
checkbox like share computer sound
you have to enable it okay
[Music]
advanced sharing options um
i don't see anything like that
you can't share your screen though right
so then just click the
the green share screen button as you
would normally
then it's gonna pop up the screen and
then it's going to say yeah if you want
to share screen one
or a program yeah
okay good so thanks thanks
did you hear now the sound uh yeah
okay perfect cool yeah how many data
scientists are required to do this
uh and makes
it very easy to train deploy perform
hyper parameter optimization
on sagemaker um just using a few
commands
okay pretty cool so what's the um what's
the elevator pitch for the demo what are
we
gonna run so we are going to
uh build the classifier on the iris data
set
okay so no mnist thank you
[Laughter]
another boring data set um
and then uh training on the cloud on
sagemaker and then deployed as a restful
endpoint
on sagemaker as well uh and we're gonna
do it
in maybe 10 minutes all right let's go
yeah the floor is yours thank you let's
do this i will just ask silly questions
cool let's have a quick look on the data
set it's called iris data set
i'm pretty sure many of you already know
that
it's about finding which class of
irish flower every sample is
it consists of four attributes or four
features okay
and it has three labels okay so three
types of flowers right
exactly okay so
you can see here the data set so
four features and the label okay
all right fair enough so you you're
gonna learn about flowers too today
exactly so um the data set is on s3
[Music]
i'm trying to make it very realistic for
real world
so most companies have their data on s3
sure
so it's under satisfied demo
and here is the iris data okay
just a text file right just a text file
exactly
exactly and then i'm going to github
and i'm going to create a new repository
all right
we're gonna call it sage-ify demo
all right let's do readme let's have an
ignore for python
that's it let's clone it
the repository okay getting into
the repository and then we need to
create a
virtual environment as well as in python
projects i usually
i usually use anaconda
so it's conda create
and you could do this on uh on a
notebook instance as well right
because we have a conda pre-installed if
you so it looks like i have already the
environment but uh i'll create it from
scratch okay
yeah if you're not familiar with condo
it's basically a
python package manager and you can just
simply create different environments so
let's say if you want to have a
self-contained environment for let's say
tensorflow
you can build that and if you want mxnet
or another tensorflow version
you can isolate your environments and
avoid doing what i've
done on countless
agents which is work with a single
python environment and
and destroy it because you upgrade the
package that doesn't
work and you break dependencies
everywhere and you have to install
everything from scratch
so uh you guys are smarter than me and
you use condo now right
exactly so i created the environment
we're going to
activate it let's clean our terminal
and then we have to install the
dependencies so
of course we need to install say define
sure
cycler pandas
usual stuff and aws
cli did i forget anything i think we're
good
okay let's install them
of course you know we're showing the
steps but you know you would have your
script to uh
exactly you know you could you would
have your script to to do all that stuff
um automatically right
all right almost there
oh border core yeah of course yeah
that's that's the actually yeah that's
actually the important one
it's required for the aws
almost
okay this should be this should be done
in a few seconds
yeah right live demos you're gonna see
everything
right cool the python environment is
installed
so we're going to run sage if i
does help and see all the commands here
so we see like
build cloud where we can
upload data using the cloud you can we
can train the model and we can deploy it
on sagemaker
uh but first of all we're gonna that's
that looks simple enough i mean i i
could probably use this
exactly uh the first thing we need to do
is sagify init
okay so essentially we're creating a new
project and
it asks for the name of the project so
we're going to name it of course cd5demo
it's a new project okay python3 of
course
yes and then it's really cool because it
will ask you for all the aws profiles
that you have locally
i'm going to use the ml hero profile
okay so these are
aws profiles defined in the
aws cli config file right exactly
exactly
in your home directory dot aws config
exactly okay yeah yeah all right
okay so the point is you get your the
credentials that you need to get the job
exactly and you can change them whenever
you want
okay and then your desirable
region name used one the default
and then you have to define where you
have installed the
um the requirements okay
so it was the requirements.txt
um can we pause here
sure yeah okay because i forgot to
yes i just realized it okay
okay perfect so we have created the
project
and then we are going to use python to
just open and create the training and
predict logic
so let's use python
so
we're going to open a new project
documents
okay here we are so
it has created the source directory
under this we have sage defy and then we
have
it has all this boilerplate code like
the docker file
everything that you need to essentially
train your model
on sagemaker all right and then you have
to go to the train file
and if you scroll a bit okay zoom in a
bit
because that's probably hard to read
yeah great thanks
that is a train function okay and then
you have input data path
this is where your training data will
live
this is where you're going to save your
model okay this is optional if you have
passed the hyper parameters
through a json file okay and this is
where you're going to save any failure
so you see here to-do's so essentially
you have to
replace these to-do's with your modeling
logic
okay so let's do that so first thing is
that we're going to import
pandas and we're going to
read the training date okay so data
frame
pd read
csv it was a csv sure and then
it's what we're doing here is we're
concatenating
the input data path
okay and then remember the iris data
file it was called iris dot data okay
essentially that is the full path to our
training data okay and then the next
step is to say that there was no header
yeah no column names exactly and then
the new column names i'm just going to
call them
fit one for feature one okay fit two
fit three fit
and then the last one of course oops
the last one is the label sure
cool and then x is going to hold the
features only
we need one more bracket
y is going to hold only the labels okay
and we do dot values
to essentially get the numpy array sure
okay almost done so then it's a good
practice to train the data setting to
train
and test data set so from scikit-learn
dot model selection
we import train test split
yeah that's a good one to know and
uh also we are going before we go into
the modeling side let's split the data
i forgot that
so
so train test split and we give the
x y then it's the
test size sure uh so 30
of the data will be used as a test data
set and then
uh it's a good practice to use the
random state
yeah to uh to avoid splitting in the
same way all the time yeah
exactly and then we're going to use
support vector machines
it was a big thing 15 years ago
it still works
um so
so while pavlos is doing that so here
we're you know we're kind of skipping
steps in the sense that um of course you
would probably
write and and experiment this code in on
jupiter in the notebook
either locally or notebook instance with
a
a fraction of the data set here it's
obviously a very small data set but
imagine you have you know 100 gigabytes
of data maybe you would grab
one gigabyte you know write this code
make it work
uh and then train it on stage maker to
scale right
so if you're new to machine learning we
would actually
probably write this code first debug it
test it on a subset of the data set and
then
once we're happy that it works we want
to train
at full scale and we would just
integrate our working code
into this right that's probably what you
do right exactly okay
good that's the process so these two
lines
and we just trained in svm so simple
okay yeah yeah scikit-learn is is
brilliant
all the math is hidden so then we are
going to evaluate that
in order to evaluate so we have to
essentially make predictions
on the test data set okay and compare
two labels of course
exactly yep so x test
and we're going to use the accuracy
metric for that reason
so again scikit learn dot
metrics import accuracy score
and then the accuracy equals
accuracy score where
we give as the y true is the y test
and then our predictions
that's perfect right yep i think
everything is done
and then the final bit is that we need
to save the model
yes and it's a good practice to save
also the accuracy
in another file okay like our report yes
so from sklearn and externals we import
something called joblib that will help
us to
serialize the model and deserialize it
later
so we need to construct the model path
which of course
is going to be the concatenation
of the model save path yeah that's an
important
bit and sometimes it confuses people who
get started with uh
with sagemaker you have to save the
model in a very specific place
okay so sagemaker will actually tell you
where to save it and
so you have to use that path which is
local
to your container and then and then at
the end of the training job
once that code has saved the model
locally to the container
sagemaker will actually take the model
from that location and copy it to s3
right in the in the s3 prefix that you
defined in your training job okay so
a lot of people say oh my training job
failed the training job
itself probably worked but you saved the
model in the wrong place so sagemaker
doesn't find it and
of course it fails okay so pay attention
where you save the model
okay just uh exactly and here it's
hidden you just need to save it
somewhere that you don't know exactly
what is it
and then you do job leap dot dump you
pass in the classifier that is trained
and the path to save it it's going to be
saved in a
file called model.pkl
and then we need to save also the
accuracy in a file
so we're going to do it in a simple way
again we have to define the report path
is again
going to be in the same location where
the model is saved
and we're going to call it report.txt
okay super simple
and then we've open
the report path and we want to be able
to write there
as if f dot right
we stringify the accuracy it's going to
be a float
and i think it's almost done
you can have the usual indentation
problem
in python
tabs or spaces
we need a full conference on that one
it's reformatted
okay all right cool perfect okay so
we're ready right yeah exactly so loaded
the data set
split it trained
support virtual machines and
scored and save the model
and the score pretty much yep that's it
okay
um so let's go and if you're not
familiar with sklearn
we had a session today on that okay so
uh yeah
so uh i'm looking at uh a scalar
and typical algo so uh go watch that one
and then
you'll understand everything in there
that's perfect
cool cool stuff so then what we need to
do is
do sage if i build
so let me guess yeah it's building the
container
based on the boilerplate code and the
code we had
exactly okay exactly so it will take
some minutes
so yeah the docker image is built all
right uh so now we are ready to train
the model on the cloud
let's go so it's really easy it's
sage-ify
cloud train and then you have
to specify where on s3 the data leaves
so it's s35
demo that's it okay
and then we have to specify where
exactly to save the model
and the report.txt file so it's going to
be in the same bucket
but under output all right and then we
have to specify the ec2 type
okay and it's going to be
just randomly chosen ml m5 large
probably it's too big for that task okay
do you support uh spot instances
uh i think they're supported now but
they are or they are in sagemaker but
does the tool allow for that
uh no no at the moment pull request full
request i'm waiting for that
dash dash spot okay or direct enable
spot all right pull request please
that would be really nice it will save
me a lot of money
all right here we go that's it
so here it says no i am role provided
it's okay uh it uses the one that we
used in the beginning dml hero
but if let's say you have changed the
profile
you can pass in one here a different one
it's a completely dynamic
and we get the logs here so it's
starting the training zone
so if we go to the aws console
and go to sagemaker
yeah we should see the training job
right and go to the training jobs
hopefully we see that there is one
training job in progress
okay and we see here that the training
has been completed okay
and the the logs in red essentially are
the logs
from our training logic okay okay
so the training is successful and we can
see here
the s3 location okay all right so no
difference from
using the sagemaker sdk here i mean we
get the the model artifact as a
a zipped uh tar file so okay
if you're exactly if you know sagemaker
you know this
and then what we need to do is to go and
deploy
that model as a restful endpoint okay so
it's really simple
what you do say defy cloud deploy this
time
and of course you have to specify the s3
model location
okay so s3 model location
our favorite copy paste yes
and then we have to specify the ec2 type
let's use a small one t to
medium okay then the number of instances
let's use one okay and then we can give
also
a name to the endpoint
let's call it my awesome
point yes because it is
here we go and that's it
awesome the endpoint is deployed we can
see that from the logs
okay so we can go quickly to the console
as we
see my awesome endpoint yep
see in service nice okay
nothing happening yet but all right cool
and then we could go to our favorite
postman
yeah and send the features okay so now
we
okay we pretend we you know we drove
somewhere and find an iris flower
and and we measured those four
dimensions and we want to know
exactly and see what type of iris is it
let's go we're going to call the
endpoint
and here you are it's a setoza
so simple okay so yeah http posting to
the endpoint exactly so yeah guys
uh that was a demo of uh of satisfy
and you know it's um it gives you um
a flavor of you know of the interfaces
that you know usually
ml platforms have you know in some of
the big uh
thing called bunnies so um
[Music]
yeah that was the presentation in
a while but uh well we don't have
probably
nothing else to do these days so yeah
thanks
thank you very much pablo thank you
thank you pablo
any any questions i i see i see
some questions in the in the chat um
uh maybe is one from from murillo
whether we you can share the
presentation deck
pablo oh yeah yeah yeah
absolutely i'll share it with you guys
uh and then
are you gonna post it on what can
possible meet up yes
cool and there is a question
from ganesh uh with a z
uh sage if i see if it supports step
functions
uh no no at the moment
i i have one question and it's about
i mean you do you deploy the rest
endpoint so you you have
you call the api and how how does it
work if you want to update the model so
um um with this edge file do you have a
downtime or
is there a way to handle um
is there a way to handle it somehow yeah
that's a good question so yeah at the
moment yeah if you
uh yeah if you redeploy that you may
have a little bit of a downtime
so uh one way to do that is to
essentially version
the uh use some kind of versioning of
the endpoint name
on the flag that it has and so every
time you
you know read a new one you can say you
know v2 v3 before
uh then once you know it's deployed you
can go and delete the previous one
okay yeah
and does it work for uh
batch processing or how do you deal with
that
good question yeah there is uh there is
one more command uh
cd5 cloud uh i think i call it batch
transform batch prediction
where essentially once you have deployed
the restful endpoint
uh you can specify uh in the batch
prediction functionality an s3
location where you have all the features
uh
the name of the endpoint and where an s3
to save the predictions
and you know it's done for you
automatically
okay cool and then how do you deal with
the
the separation of concerns between
feature engineering or preparing
features and creating features and
storing them on
an s3 versus training do you deal with
training
thinking about getting everything ready
for you and then only
spinning up something for like as a
framework the hyper parameters and blah
blah blah
how do you deal with these stuff you
know
yeah you know there are many uh schools
here
uh what i've seen working really well is
to have a complete separation
so with the feature engineering part uh
where essentially you know you may have
you know a complex you know spark job
that generates the training
data and um you know you save them
somewhere in s3
um and then you know um if it is bad
prediction is perfect you know you can
reuse the same but
spark job to generate the features for
prediction
it's getting tricky when it comes to uh
if you know your website wants to call
this because they have to follow the
same logic for you know
essentially calculating the features so
here you know ideas like feature store
can help
um for example uh
but yeah it's uh i think that's that's a
very
you know uh big discussion i think
how to do it properly cool thank you
sure
there's one more question published in
the chat which is from mine as he asked
whether
there is a provision for online training
online training so it's not supported
like easily so what you can do
is um i've seen that with uh
contextual multi-arm bandits for
essentially you know you have to
incrementally
train a model what you can do is that
you know the training logic you have to
load the previously trained model
uh do an incremental train
and save it back on s3 uh and have you
know some kind of
wrapper job that you know finds but
it runs i don't know you can have a
lambda where around some every couple of
minutes
checks if there is you know latest safe
model industry
and if that happens then you know you
deploy the new version
uh if it is deployed then you delete the
previous one and you know you move like
this so
it's it's not real time online it's like
you know
uh mini bats uh online learning
a follow-up on that actually is that a
limitation of change maker
not so much of the tool but more sure of
the platform at the moment
yeah yeah it's a limitation of all the
ml engines to be honest
at the moment so they they all of them
were designed in this
format that you know of classic
supervised
model uh where you know you always you
know separate the train test
and you do some you know you build new
models i know
every day maybe every hour at most
but yeah they they haven't solved the
real-time
uh online uh learning to be honest
maybe you want to build a startup
there's one more question in the chat by
the way feel free to
open your mics and ask the questions if
you want but i'm happy to read them as
well
um so valeria is asking how would you
handle requests while you are deleting
one model
and have not yet deployed the new one
yeah that's a good question so yeah
because if you add the
so if you add new features
uh
[Music]
to your model that will be able to
to serve your uh still serve request the
old model
so that would be you know for a small
time of time
of time you know you may have like
really weird predictions but if you come
off completely change the features um
yeah you need to synchronize when the
client side is gonna call the new model
uh in order to do that so here we're
talking about you know
more tricky stuff uh where you know your
engineering team
needs to you know you need to coordinate
with your engineering team
um so yeah it's
um you know blue green deployments this
kind of stuff on sagemaker can be
a tricky or in fact or more on most ml
engines
i think the one tool that is really cool
is the best one in deployments is
seldom.io to be honest
uh they're the most advanced but they
focus only on deployments
i have a question for you pablos yeah um
so certified is an abstraction on top of
sagemaker of course
and is there are there any thoughts on
extending that to
gcp maintaining the api
but using a different backend yeah
i want to do that i don't know if you
guys want to step
in as uh you know contributors uh
um so yeah um by the way yeah if you if
you want to step in as a contributor
just uh you know ping me
uh just that you know i didn't have the
time yet to do that
um but that that was the whole premise
of sagify that you know it will be the
abstraction on top of
gcp as well or any other you know ml
lensing that
is you know out there
any other questions from anyone in the
chat or
feel free to open the mic and ask of
course
i have a small question the if you were
to integrate
this in like a csd pipeline how like
what would be like a simple example
for
how how would you go about doing that
okay
yeah i mean yeah it can be like yeah
jenkins anything so what you could do
is that you know um
[Music]
you could have like you know one jenkins
job that is responsible to you know
to find new training data on s3 specific
let's say
latest data date if you have splitted
the
the paths on date and then essentially
call either the
emulate the call to the terminal says 85
cloud train
but also i have the python apis so you
can do it programmatically if you want
that
um and then wait until you know the
model is trained
that's the tricky part with jenkins
because it may timeout
so and then later you can have one more
step
that essentially you know if the first
one is successful you deploy
the model so it's you know we we're used
to
have like in cicd you know the you know
build
test deploy so now you have to build
a train deploy
cool things and if i understand
correctly if you if you start the
training process
it doesn't sort of start it and then
drop back to the terminal it will it
will sort of wait until until it's
oh you have an option you can wait it
can i can hold
or it can trigger it and just then you
can continue
okay is there a way to sort of monitor
it while it's training or
that goes back into maker essentially
yeah you have to go to sagemaker so
um yeah so i so many things that
you know we could do no yeah i know you
but okay cool so it's back to stage week
so yeah you can uh the it's it the seed
speaker is the key is fine just you know
it has become gigantic um
and uh yeah you can you can monitor
training jobs
so this is quite easy you can see you
know if it is in progress
failed success etc so that's quite easy
cool thanks yeah sure
there's another one um question
on the chat that says whether there are
any resources
that you can share with us uh in regards
to merlots
for example you know who to follow on
twitter any blogs
podcasts that you know we can uh
sort of read or hear after that if we're
interested to hear
to learn more yeah cool uh i'll add one
more slide
with all these resources so when i share
the slides with you guys it will be
everything in one place
perfect
any other questions anyone and
we have some more time
i have yet another question for you
pavlos is
how does uh sedgify
or you know or another tool as well but
um
how does this envelopes framework work
with uh
dvc uh essentially
and you know like dvc
nowadays doesn't only happen you know it
allows you to retrain
maybe there is a way that you know you
can use some of these tools to
throw back the reproducibility pipeline
on the dvc
um in the cloud but also there is a ci
cd4 machine learning
component of dvc so is there is there
any
um way these two tools can work together
or
they don't combine very well i think
i mean you you can as far as remember
you can also version you know
uh data with pvc uh so
that's that's a good thing where you can
complement that aspect that you don't
have here
so you can start versioning this thing
and you can version the output
so the model that is saved on s3 so then
you have a really good lineage
that tells you okay i i
versioned the data set i know that
you know that was the cd maker training
job
that was used and then you know the the
model output is this one so you can
essentially use it on top of satisfy
um so i would i could see this
this scenario to complement the two of
them
make sense any other questions
in which case crystal should we should
we say thank you and
say buy and stuff i think so
so if if you notice in the chat
there is a link to a slug channel we
made
we creatively named it psi data
so if you want to join i mean we're
trying to really to build
also the community here in cyprus uh it
would be nice if
we can discuss um in there so feel free
to
they invited there feel free to join
cool that's perfect yeah
and i guess with that uh yeah have a
have a good night
cool thanks guys thanks everyone for
joining us
thanks everyone